main cabin masters on DIY Network and
one of the stars in fact I think he
believes he is the star
he's Ryan elders joins us on the program
Ryan good morning how are you how we
doing today Dan 5 10 to 10 and crispix
okay Oh crispix is your serial choice
that is my serial okay are you guys
working today are you doing any mini
building today we are not building yes
we'll start up in about three weeks
we're kind of going through the scouting
process right now figuring out where
we're gonna be and kind of watching the
weather there's a ton of snow up here so
we're gonna have to probably work
towards the coast the first round
how did DIY Network find you guys yeah
you know we're very lucky my niece is
best friend's mother worked for the
Kennebec land trust typical and
production company out of Denver dorsey
productions reached out to them looking
for builders or people who resale up
sale across they'll recycle all that and
ashley chasing my father-in-law had a
little shop and howl along main but they
were doing the barn board thing and all
that things all the things that really
in right now but well before their time
well since then the shop is closed but
you know they were known for saving
stuff recycling upcycle and never throw
anything away we fit the mold they
called us next thing we knew we're doing
a Skype interview and we're doing a
pilot I was allowed Dory I was also
wondering I would always say main cabin
builders and then Holly goes its main
cabin masters ok what's what's the
difference there in main cabin builders
or you're a master yeah I think the
master is a TV thing maybe to get
people's attention okay no I'm not sure
if a lot of people are calling to watch
main cabin builders but you know Masters
has a ring dude okay if somebody hasn't
seen this show how would you describe we
like to say you know this old house kind
of meet signs held you know some humor
with a little talent in there any fights
oh geez all the time you know if chase
isn't mad at me he's mad at us
so you know I prefer that they're going
at it you know and we work 40 50 hours a
week together a lot of times we're
spending times away from our families
and homes together so you know we get on
each other's nerves but end of the day
we're in a beautiful spot we're dealing
with great people you know and you get
you put it behind you you know there's
there's a lot of stress in it with the
deadlines and you know travel and
logistics and it all comes to a head
every once in a while but that's one
thing we were 100% sure we wanted to
stay true and not portray on TV it's
fighting we know we don't fight a lot
but we get edgy sometimes but it's all
this family friends stuff you see every
day but Ryan have you ever gotten to one
of these cabins and just said no we
can't we can't do there's no it's no
spot at many times I chased chase was
definitely wouldn't you know let that
happen you know a lot of these cabins
should get a match or be torn down but
what we do is with saving memories you
know a lot of these people spend this
money just to save the memories of these
camps and you know it's amazing you know
how important that is to some families
and some people and you know it's
awesome when we give the camp back a
camp that did it people didn't think
would get saved and to see the reaction
you know it's priceless it's and it's
worth all the hard work and the hours
away from home in a long day's and you
know what I watch like diners drive-ins
and dives and then I'll watch main cabin
masters building Alaska and I have no
interest in I can't build anything and I
can't cook anything so I don't know why
I'm watching these shows why are we
watching you guys work you know I think
our success is that we're just you know
we're real people can relate to us you
know we're just a bunch of builders from
Maine who got very lucky you know and a
trying our hardest to portray me in the
right way you know and to promote the
trades and you know everyone has a fun
like one of us whether it's myself or
Jedi or Dixie or Ashley or the guys that
you see behind the scenes you know
people can relate to us you know what
it's just good to see you know good fun
stuff that you couldn't like too
especially today when there's a lot of
you know negative stuff going on it's
just fun easy TV you don't have to
really think much you do lead the league
and showing up hungover of the group
there
Oh some days some days I do you know
we're I always say you got to pay to
play and it doesn't get as easy as you
get as old yeah I think your sisters the
MVP though she's sneaky great that you
know she's snarky white are your wife I
should say she caps it together she's
sneaky great um and you know I I love
that I love her approach and she's a
sniper like she'll just come in and you
know get say something jab and then move
out yeah she's one of a kind I'll tell
you I'm very very lucky
um her sense of humor you don't her
ability to work with guys you know
sometimes it's her and 10 or 12 guys up
north of the camp you know it she holds
her own she's not afraid you know she's
uh just she's almost like a black-clad
she's a master at wrestling when she
needs to having fun when she needs to do
and working when she needs to she just
perfect time it doesn't matter what it
is she needs to do that attribute she'll
bust it out yeah Brian Eldridge main
cabin masters on DIY Network I know big
Patriots fan you got to go to the Super
Bowl this year I did I got very lucky
went down to the Super Bowl what a game
how did you get recognized I did yeah
it's it's just kind of wild everywhere
we go we're getting recognized more and
more taking pictures and you know my
buddies that I was with thought it was
it's got a got a bigger kick out of it
than I did but um yeah even I even I've
been those section 311 there I had some
people that knew me and so it was fun
what if oh good brady and giselle call
and saying you know what we need we're
looking for a lakeside cabin can you
help us yeah we would definitely help
them or you would know he's probably
crossed state lines for that one you
know it would be illegal could you teach
my guys like you know this show pretty
has no ability whatsoever Paulie I think
wants to McLovin has no interest seaton
might be able to but could you like how
long would it take if I sent my guys up
there
oh jeez we could get them whipped up in
a day or two you know I have an English
degree my wife has an art you know
creative design degree Dixie you went
for business you know with
we didn't start out as carpenters you
know we just realized we wanted to work
outside and you know the beautiful state
of Maine work with our hands you know
they have it your your team we should do
a build someday we'll get you a new set
or something oh I think I'd rather have
a cabin up there on a lake and and it
they're always on the lake right every
one of the cabins is on the link ninety
percent of them are on water sure okay
yeah yeah it's we're very lucky that way
once in a while we'll get one that's
close to water something but you know
they like that on TV you know and it's
just a great work environment it plays
well for the everything that's going on
with the show and you listen on the the
big job in Portland yeah well on the big
Jay 96.3
yeah funny you know you guys showed out
to the show a lot I'm always in and out
of my truck and I'm always missing it so
my phones blowing hop and I gotta go
back and listen to it but yeah we we
appreciate all of you guys have given us
and we love the big jab too and maybe
maybe won't come up there one time maybe
we'll let you know we'll be in the
neighborhood and we'll bring beer we
would love you guys come up and bring
beer will provide the beer just get up
here well Ryan congratulations on all
the success with the show it's fun watch
and are you still in a boot or is that
is that an old old episode that I'm
watching that was that was an old injury
I'm fine now I'm going to get back at it
do you have all your toes and fingers
I'm doing all right and be a lot cooler
if you didn't but you know I'm knocking
on wood okay
Thank You Ryan hey thanks dance I think
the dance we appreciate all the support
guys I'm Ryan Eldridge he's one of the
main cabin masters for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
at
you